Google Cloud updates generative AI
continues to develop at a blistering
pace so it's absolutely critical to have
Enterprise ready capabilities to
leverage this disruptive technology and
that's why we're excited to announce the
general availability of four important
foundation models for vertex AI Imogen
Palm 2 for chat Kodi and Chirp for each
of these models organizations can access
apis on model garden and do prompt
design and tuning on generative AI
studio and for even more AI make sure
you're registered and ready for next
2023 the entire course catalog is
available online so make sure that
you're strategizing your sessions labs
and networking what sessions are you
most excited for check out the links for
everything that we covered on this
week's